Now don't get all overwhelmed with
short row shaping on the double bed.
It's really, if you think of it,
it's the same as on the single bed.
The differences come into play with your
needle arrangement, stitch patterning,
needles out of work, and maybe racking,
but let's start simple and look at double
bed
short row shaping with one
by one short row decreases.
When you're working one by one ribbing,
the garment stitch count is spread over
both beds.
For example, in this image, I have 21
stitches in work 11 on the main bed, 10 on
the ribber, right?
This isn't the case for all variations of
full needle rib, but for right now, let's
concentrate on 1x1
ribbing.
My instructions are to decrease five
stitches every other row X number of
times.
Now, if you're working on a single bed,
you'd set your carriage to hold, pull out
five needles to hold position, knit two
rows, wrapping the needles to prevent
holes.
We're going to do just the same
thing with one by one ribbing.
We'll start by setting both
carriages to hold both directions.
Opposite the carriage, pull
five needles into hold position.
That's one main bed.
One ribber bed, one main bed, one ribber
bed, one main bed for a total of five
needles.
Going to knit to the left.
Notice that the main bed needle is closest
to the working yarn, so use that working
yarn and wrap that needle and knit back.
Pull five needles to hold.
This time it's going to be a ribber
- main - ribber -main- ribber.
Knit across and this time it's the ribber
needle that's closest to the working yarn.
Wrap that needle and knit back.
Keep repeating, putting five needles into
hold, knit, wrap, knit, across the work.
Now, just like in short rows on the main
bed, you need to adjust your weight.
You're going to have to remove the
ribber comb and use weight hangers.
Be sure there's even weight on your
knitting all the way across the bed, and
adjust the weight as your
work in the short rows.
This may be the hardest
part of this whole exercise.
So pay attention to the
position of the stitches.
And the formation of the stitches that are
in the needles in work as you knit, it's
easy for them to pop off if the
weight isn't even across the knitting.
Notice that we're holding
an odd number of stitches.
The wraps are alternating from a ribber
stitch to a main bed stitch and back
again.
I specifically chose this so that
you could take a look at the wraps.
I've blocked the heck out of this swatch.
Can you see the wraps on
this side of the knitting?
Because of the odd number of stitches
and we wrapped ribber needle -  main bed
needle alternately.
Wraps showing on both
sides of the knitting.
Now, in most cases is probably doesn't
matter, but I want you to be aware of it.
So instead of decreasing five stitches, we
decreased maybe four or an even number of
stitches.
The wraps would be all on the same bed.
So you might want to determine which
side of your knitting is going to be the
private side and which side is the public
side in relation to where the wraps lay
and how visible they are.
On the other hand, you may just want to
let the chips (or the wraps) fall where they
lay and not worry about it.